this is a production of Cornell
University topic today GM crops as
catalysts for global development and I
want to point out to you that GM crops
have all really played a big part in
global agriculture but that they have a
lot more to offer and if they're handled
effectively and safely could make a big
difference to the globe and particularly
to excuse me developing countries so
those are the main points I want to make
so the actual issues I'm going to
address is very briefly what is a GM
crop does everyone here know what a GM
crop is ends up if you do I'll put my
hand up our GM crops safe when should
one use
we should one use GM crops what has been
the impact of GM crops today and I think
many of you be surprised by the extent
of the impact the enormous potential
going well beyond GM crops for global
development and suggesting a strategy
that has been using here at Cornell with
the US aid funded project on how to do
this
this work on broadening that range in a
safe manner so just for those who are a
little bit rusty and haven't been in a
biotech class for a day or two it's all
counterintuitive okay you see I'm very
hot on technology I hope you know
modified crops also known as biotech
crops
and genetically engineered crops GE
crops not developed by the Selective
addition of a trait from any source so
this is why you hear about Tomatoes they
might have fish genes in them
which scares their heck out of a lot of
people why they have bacterial genes in
them etcetera etcetera I won't go on
because there's any Greenpeace
supporters here you'll probably kill me
before I get to the next life but any
source but they aren't the main things
I'm going to be talking about whether
bacterial may be but sources such as
other plants are going to be a major
point in going to talk a lot of people
discuss the safety of GM crops you'll
find it's a little bit like whether we
should build a wall between Mexico and
America I mean USA whether Britain
should stay in brexit honor a lot of
opinions and a lot of the a lot of the
comments are made not on the basis of
fact from belief but here are two
statements I always tell my students and
the fellows not to use too many words on
the slide so I'm glad that everything in
here here at the moment they're all in
some international programs event but
the World Health Organization said in
2014 GM crop the GM foods currently
available on the international market
have passed safety assessments and are
not likely to present risks for human
health in addition no effects on human
health have been shown as a result of
the consumption of such foods by the
general public
in the countries and where they have
been approved then he got National
Academy of Sciences 2016 the study
committee found though substantiated
evidence of a difference in risks to
human health between currently
commercialized genetically engineer
de crops this case and conventionally
bred crops nor did it find conclusive
cause-and-effect evidence of
environmental problems from the GE crops
so there's a couple of pretty important
bodies saying that these crops are safe
what we need to remember is that they
need to be kept safe there needs to be
all the time like with pharmaceuticals
etc there has to be vigilance to make
sure they stay safe both in terms of
human health and animal health and the
environment so when should we used GM
crops I know some fanatics who say some
scientists who say they should be used
for everything
take over there not very many of those
people but there are some people who
believe that I say and many people
because they'd like me but my wife says
there's not too many people like me yeah
I think she means that in the positive
GM crop technology is a tool in the
toolbox not a silver bullet or cure-all
a complement to other approaches and to
use when other approaches are too
lengthy expensive or unavailable so
don't think you're looking at a sort of
fanatic who says all of you should use
GM crops all the time
one of the impact of GM crops to date
well this is what's happened in terms of
global area of biotech crops or GM crops
or GE crops from 1996 when they were
virtually none grown commercially
through 2017 you see that the total
number being grown in 2017 was one
hundred and eighty nine thousand one
hundred and eighty nine million hectares
you
hundred of the hundred and eighty nine
hundred million hectares were grown in
developing countries and 89 million in
industrialized countries which other
main traits genetic traits that are
being commercialized its herbicide
tolerance is the number one
in insect resistance and then the two
together what they call stacked traits
to put the two there are two types of
resistances together and in terms of the
principal biotech crops they are cotton
soybean maize and canola and you can see
here that there are various amounts of
the genetic engineering contributing to
the total adoption of those crops the
basic thing is that I want you to
remember is that cotton soybean maize
and canola are the main ones that are
being commercialized that herbicide
tolerance insect resistance and the
combination of those are the main traits
to be commercialized so far so what's
been the contribution of these biotech
crops to food security excuse me
sustainability and climate change I
won't dwell on any of these but I just
want to give you a picture of a study
that has been done by Brooks and Wofford
and published in 2018 these guys have
been looking at the impact of biotech
crops for years but this is the most
recent thing biotech crops have been
responsible for increased crop
productivity they've been responsible
for providing a better environment for
conserving biodiversity a point that I'm
going to come back to later reducing co2
emissions and helping alleviate poverty
and hunger by the way if anyone wishes
to have a copy of these slides I'd be
happy to send them to you perhaps at the
end I'll just put my email address up
there again so you can you can ask for
those or I can give them all to Martha
and she can send them out to people one
by 11 so that's it so far a few crops
commercialize on a big scale
a few traits that's it
so what about the rest of the story
what's the next generation of GM crops
going to be well it's going to be many
many crop bitrate combinations but here
are a few for you to look at abiotic
stress tolerance drought heat flooding
etc are going to be addressed and are
being addressed nutritional an
enhancement disease resistance these are
being addressed right now but and this
is what I find the most exciting thing
or is that there's a vast range of
traits that can be put into crop
varieties through genetic engineering so
genomics and bioinformatics are
facilitating easier identification
isolation and transfer of genes for most
agriculturally important traits so
increased ability to extract the needed
genes from plants germ plasm collections
the improved use of germ plasm
collections will strengthen conservation
efforts now last I mentioned that I
worked at the international potato
Center in Peru is a global operation
they're one of its main functions was to
to maintain and utilize a massive
collection of potatoes cultivated
potatoes wild potatoes we had just about
every single trait you can imagine
within that collection the downside was
that less than 10% 10% closer perhaps
the cylinder sent depending on who we
were writing a report for that was not
being that was being utilized to improve
crops why because through regular plan
reading you had to work first of all
identify those accessions those those
units who say within the collection that
had interesting characteristics such as
disease resistance flood tolerance etc
then through breeding you had to take
those very exciting looking at sessions
and cross them with your with the
varieties that had everything but that
then you had to spend several years back
crossing to get rid of any undesirable
traits that you crossed in through the
plant breeding with GM of course as I
said earlier on you can take a
particular trait and plug that in to the
variety
I'm not saying as easy as that you've
got to do all kinds of tests to make
sure that plugging in happened right and
there's no deleterious effects of having
put that gene into the genome etc cetera
cetera but GM can speed up the process
of plant breeding very dramatically
because you're selectively putting in
that gene you won so not only does that
give us the chance to more rapidly
develop important new varieties it also
helps to conserve germ plasm reason even
when I was at at the potato Center it
was very very difficult in crow
increasingly difficult to Maine yet the
money from donors to maintain the
collection we had even though he had
what we modestly dubbed the world's
potato germ plasm collection and and
why was that because so little of it was
actually being used to boost the
varieties around the world
what if you saw those plant collections
as collections of genes a field of genes
and you could go in there with molecular
biology and pull out the genes that you
want and plug those into the commercial
varieties or whatever that you saw
things that way you would increase the
chances of people saying hey those germ
plasm collections are now being used
much greater extent the other thing is
this would help with a perception of
many about GM crops I said at the
beginning fish genes bacterial genes at
sector etc are put into the crops what
if the main line in the future was to
take plant genes from germ plasm
collections and plug those into your
target varieties plant genes into plants
I think that might help with a
perception and perception is extremely
important part of this whole GM crop
debate that's going on I'd be happy to
discuss that at this time afterwards I'm
glad that Susan the couch is here
because if you don't understand this
statement up here she will explain it to
you much better than I could but back in
97 this was just after I started at the
World Bank the whole place was excited
because of an article by Steve Tanksley
and Susan Rakuten are not exaggerating
Susan they
said the tools of Genome Research may
finally unleash the genetic potential of
our wild and cultivated germ plasm just
what I've been talking about for the
benefit of society that was a very
exciting statement it's led to all kinds
of new thoughts about the area of GM
crops and and crop crop science in
general so that was published in science
and congratulations for doing that work
so we can move beyond a very narrow
range of traits genetic traits what
about the crops themselves the
multinational life sciences companies
have focused on internationally traded
big selling crops I mentioned them
earlier on the soy the maize the canola
etc but many crops have been overlooked
despite their nutritional and economic
importance to poor regions such orphan
crops cover two hundred and forty
million hectares in developing countries
and there's enormous potential for
genetic engineering of those orphan
crops to make them more more productive
more tolerant to climatic conditions
more resistant to diseases in sexist
Italy back in 2002
we started here at Cornell a project
which went under the unlikely name of
agricultural biotechnology support
project number two
I remember describing this to people and
say what are you working on these days
well I imagine you're at a party but I
work on the agricultural biotechnology
support project number two how fastly do
abs be - for sure
ABS p1 was a run by Michigan State they
did a lot of work - to help educate
people around the world about biotech
crops and did some support of some good
research and so on but when it came to
the next phase
ABS b2 we were asked if we would lead
that and we work with a whole bunch of
institutions not only in the United
States in India and Africa Bangladesh
Philippines the focus of ABS BC was to
try to develop GM crops in Africa and
Asia in accordance with what was in
demand there
remember that I caused quite a stir at
USAID when I sent in a proposal which
was contributed to by many many people
and it basically said we don't know what
we're gonna do in the first six months
the imagine this went really really well
in Washington even had a phone call
about it not congratulating me on this
brilliance but what do you mean you
don't know what you're gonna do so what
there's one thing we did mention we're
going to find out what we're going to do
we're going to get together with
appropriate groups public private sector
etc in these various countries who've
been asked to work in ask them what they
want then we work out whether it's
feasible to work on those things huh so
we did we did that and this this
projects been going on well it went on
for 12 years now there's big fragments
of it splitting off into sub sub
projects and abs b2 itself no longer
exists but it went for 12 years and I
think it totaled about 880 million
dollars I know to some of you molecular
biologists and people eighty million
dollars is just chump change you know at
the time it seemed like a lot of money
to me anyway
the entire budget of the potato Center
was 25 million a year so you can imagine
that getting 80 million was nice so
let's see
as I say at Cornell University
University USA LED consortium that
complemented Asian and African national
efforts to use GM crops safely and
effectively it was a we decided on a
product driven approach meaning all the
activities would be around a product
meaning a particular GM crop we wanted
to boost productivity and sustainability
we wanted to strength through the
products themselves we wanted to
strengthen national and regional biotech
capacity and partnerships and build a
portfolio of success stories about
impact in farmer's fields so we had that
aspect impact assessment built in right
forth right from the start we my
American colleagues particularly didn't
like this because Sir Arthur helps was
an Englishman but he said nothing
succeeds like success we wanted to show
what was successful in this project and
then catalyze more and more success
this is what Ronnie Kaufman elegantly
caused our petal diagram imagine
importing a petal diagram after the
flowers petals brilliant piece of
strategy put together by myself and all
these others working this project come
up with this fantastic strategy and he
calls it a kettle diagram but anyway so
much for Ronnie who's not here so I can
insult him as much as I like but
basically this this here was the essence
of the of the strategy we used and the
main thing I want you to to realize if
you don't already is that developing a
genetically engineered crop or GM crop
it's not just the matter going into the
lab using a gene gun or agro bacterium
mediated transfer of genes into a
cropping doing selections after that you
have to think about many different
things and we try to harness ideas
coming from all angles and put them all
into each of the products that we worked
on first of all it had to be demand
driven it had to be agreed upon by the
countries working on this that this was
something they wanted they had to be
feasible to do it had to take a holistic
integrated approach that took into
account technology development itself
marketing and distribution policy
including intellectual property rights
and regulatory issues outreach and
communication once Santos has so much
struggle with GM crops because they
virtually ignored outreach and
communication to the public so the
opponents of GM crops could come up with
all kinds of things and Ron Center was
not poised well to combat those things
they had not provided public with facts
even though they had masses of facts
when I was a beltway bandit the two
years in Washington sort consultants and
so
one of my Jobs was to review and develop
packages regulatory packages for GM
crops one of the clients was Monsanto
and you will be amazed by how much
detail they're going to each time they
produce one of these crops in terms of
the safety assessments sometimes ten or
more years of research goes into that
for health environment then you've got a
a framework here of consisting of the
FDA USDA EPA working together in
coordinated fashion to assess the safety
data that come out on each of those
crops none of that was commuted commuted
to thee or communicated to to the public
by Monsanto brilliant science that he
did but having not looked at the
outreach and communication very
carefully it was very tough for them
then of course we were doing
public/private efforts we were building
capacity within the countries to not
only develop but to assess the safety
and efficacy of the crop and also
developing this capacity for product
stewardship looking at the product the
GM crop after it had been released
we selected several several products
after discussions with the various
nations fruit and shoot borer of
pest major pest of eggplant in India
Bangladesh Philippines late blight
resistant potato India Bangladesh
Indonesia disease and nematode resistant
bananas in Uganda I won't go through all
of these but all each of those is either
commercialized like the fruit and shoot
for a resistant eggplant in Bangladesh
that has already been commercialized and
it's on the market and I'll give you a
summary of the other things in the
minute but there either
commercialized or on track for that
these products were initiated but
discontinued we thought we set ourselves
up as just like a corporation see how
things go something isn't going that's
it no research for the sake of it
so papaya ringspot drought and salt
tolerance in rice laws both virus
resistant the tailor and tobacco Street
virus in ground up
we stopped each one of those and
stopping one or two of those almost made
me cry by the way I should point out
that the person who's been leading this
project extremely effectively for most
of its existence is dr. Frank shock
Koski who is an adjunct professor in
plant breeding in genetics very close
colleague and friend of mine and he came
in after we had developed this whole
concept and got the thing launched and
all that and he was absolutely the right
guy to do it because he used to be a
product manager in Syngenta which is
very strong on GM crops
it was almost almost perfect I'm not
going to details about why US aid didn't
want to continue with me as the director
but anyway it turned out that they had
much more vision than I thought and
Frank came on board and he was
absolutely terrific and he's not working
on it anymore I'll be doing on other
things all over the place all right so
we just taking one example of where I
think abs be two moves successful look
at the eggplants now eggplant for most
of you something you have if you're not
particularly hungry after you've had a
meal I mean it's just on the side for
most people but in India Bangladesh
Philippines for example it's a staple
food it's extremely important
it's a crop of great economic and
nutritional importance in India four
hundred and seventy thousand hectares
alone are grown and it's common to all
income groups there was a 50 to 70
percent yield loss fifty to seventy
percent yield loss due to the fruit and
shoot fora in India alone chemical pest
control measures were not working to the
extent there was massive overuse of
chemicals major threat to health and
environment there were stories of so
much pesticide being around in farms
where they could actually afford it that
the kids were drinking it and stirring
it with their their arms and things like
that the farmers were so worried about
the amount of pesticide they were using
they didn't consume their own produce
they would only sell it
and the fruit and shoot for like so many
insects insect pest develops resistance
to the chemicals that have been thrown a
point
also the increasing cost of chemical
pesticide Shrunk the farmers profit so
is a absolute disaster we got together a
team of globally renowned scientists to
look at this situation we've been told
by the countries that they wanted
something done about this this was the
top priority but we wanted to know was
any alternative to using GM crops
basically the answer was no conventional
breeding was unfeasible there were no
agronomic practices that would that
would cope with this insect and that if
bt eggplant genetically engineered
eggplant BT I'll come back to in a
second bacillus thuringiensis eggplant
it it was considered by economists we
have viable alternative to the chemicals
and I put this up here my wife is a an
artist and I thought you might also
appreciate that picture it's actually of
Bt toxin or one of them really amazing
and all kinds of changes can be made to
that that molecule to make it effective
in different ways but anyway getting
back to the main point here the BT G
that was used in this eggplant was cry
one AC and it is from bacillus
thuringiensis it produces an
insecticidal protein that has a toxic
effect on many caterpillars including
fruit and shoot Bora the
transgenic eggplants containing
this beatty came from a company called
Mexico Maharashtra hybrid seed company
they had already developed some egg
plants that were resistant to the fruit
and sheep aura but they did not want to
follow through with with
commercialization but he's not by
themselves
so this was a tremendous step forward
but they were willing to donate that to
this project our project pro bono free
of charge so we not only had that we had
the history of BT crops
which was ABT had been used in many
different crops around the world for
decades and had been highly highly
effective and safe in terms of the
environment and health so the expected
impacts of bt eggplant India was there'd
be reduction of crop losses we did this
with economists and biologists and so on
reduced health and environmental risks
savings in crop production costs
positive economic impact was estimated
164 million dollars per annum just in
India alone and provision of food to
several million people at affordable
prices the current status of bt eggplant
commercialization is that in Bangladesh
as I mentioned
there's already commercialization of
this this crop this BT insect-resistant
April nearly a fifth of Bangladeshi
eggplant farmers are cultivating BT
eggplant in the Philippines it's in the
process of being released commercially
hopefully this year it will happen but
you never know there can be an
intervention at the last minute by the
opponents of GM crops with the
government
and that can hold up things again and
this is what happened in India India was
meant to be our flagship this is where
this was going to go straight through
and it had all the green lights you can
imagine the various ministries and
groups and this and that and the other
and trials had been extremely successful
and at the last minute Greenpeace and
its colleagues got in touch with the
Ministry of Environment which was the
sort of last step along the governmental
chain that had to be addressed and
told them that this was very very
dangerous
vt eggplant was very very dangerous so
that's on hold at the moment so if you'd
like to find out more information about
this whole subject you can either go and
read a thousand articles and books in
the man library or you can look at this
brilliant paper oh yeah by myself and
some other people including Frank shot
cost you see there and you can get an
idea of what our plan was what the
background was for this the project is
strategy Frank and I are working on a
paper now which would be published in GM
crops and food which summarizes the
entire progress that was made during the
12 years this one down below is one that
I wrote with a couple of colleagues in
is the work we did in South Africa I
didn't want to include it here because
we're pretty short of time but I was
asked to go to South Africa as a
consultant and assess the impact of bt
cotton insect resistant cotton on the
Zulu farmers of an area called
kwazulu-natal and this paper here
summarizes what was found what I could
say is that having shown you all those
graphs global this global that this
brings it right down to the personal
level went there and I found that the
Zulu farmers their only cash crop was
cotton that the American ball worm was
destroying their crops just like in the
case of the eggplant masses and masses
of pesticides have been put on to save
their only cash profit I'm sorry I I
should have asked you all to turn off
your cell phones whose is that oh it's
mine I'm sorry but basically they were
in a mess and the idea was to try and
write up something about the way in
which this cotton had been introduced
the importance to the farmers and so on
I remember at one stage I don't know how
many of you know about the history of
the British and the Zulus but it wasn't
all pleasant and very difficult people
they didn't like to be conquered by the
British for some reason I guess there's
some people around here felt the same
way and basically this the only amusing
part of all this was it in a circle
around me in this village they all had
these farming implements which were
looking more and more like weapons to me
and they asked this Africana guy from
Delta and pine who I was with was
shepherding me to in their language they
said is this man going to take away our
special cotton and the africana
told me afterwards because you know
afrikaners and the Brits had a little
bit of a scuffle called the Boer War and
he said to me afterwards you can't
imagine what agony I was in he was a
chance to say yes
and get revenge but anyway but the fact
was it's very very important to them
well let's get on to the serious
business of perception again everything
was going great they got back their cash
crop because of the Bt cotton within a
couple of years a disaster happen the
cotton crop went the Bt cotton crop
terrible it was a major drought and
various other things took place so that
their cotton industry collapsed the game
I must say it was just a temporary thing
but you can imagine by oh watch for
example which is a closely allied to
Greenpeace etc they wrote an article
pointing out how bt cotton was no use to
the Zulus just as they said there's no
sustainability associated with this blah
blah blah blah blah then another group
luckily wrote in nature that in fact
this drop in the cotton industry had
nothing to do with bt cotton
was to do with cotton prices having for
various nasty things happening with the
South African currency the rent with the
drought nothing at least eight had
nothing to do with the BT
so these are the kind of perceptions
they had to watch out for I'm not saying
that everything's perfect about GM crops
I'm not saying that there will not be
problems in the future
but I am saying be careful what you
believe the ultimate story here with
regard to giving a misperception that's
five misperception is I was in an OECD
conference in Paris and a Englishman
stood up
showed a correlation between the
introduction of GM crops into Britain
before they banned them ago and the
death rates of a certain British bird it
was a fabulous correlation if you don't
like birds so perfect
well the reporters went rushing out
started writing their papers and
everything on it
they didn't stay for the question the
questions were interesting but the best
one was this another Englishman who
happened to know about the scene in
Britain he said excuse me there's just
one fallacy with your argument here that
GM crops kill birds that bird is only
found in the highlands of Scotland
there is no agriculture in that
particular ecosystem in that particular
part of it those birds don't even come
across crops let alone GM crops could
you explain to me what the cause and
effect is on but next day in the
newspapers headline GM crops killed
birds in England Scotland sorry John but
can you imagine this is the kind of
thing you have to watch out for I'm not
saying that everyone is against GM crops
is wrong there are valid arguments to be
made but make sure they're valid before
you go off saying GM crops kill birds in
Britain
you very much
[Applause]
damn which Oh soybean issue I don't know
what the case of theirs envied by many
Indians who wanted to adopt the BT
eggplant technology and just as their
rivals in cricket
they're rivals in GM crops too the
problem is that with a Ministry of
Environment saying you can't do it that
was that but there's there's a lot of
envy there and I think that Bangladesh
is going to shoot ahead in terms of the
business side of the eggplant and not
only in Bangladesh but also in in the
international market as well that
business in Brazil and Argentina there's
tremendous rivalry between Argentina and
Brazil as many of you are know in soccer
what they call football and the when the
Brazilians stopped
commercializing GM crops and soybean
particular because the Argentine's
business in that area shot up for export
and within the country in zone and
Brazilians were really upset because
there's so much competitiveness between
the countries and they that actually
that feeling actually had an effect on
the Brazilian Parliament so crazy stuff
which is what level safety do you think
we have to oversee moving native
genetics around I think especially it's
too high and we'll just go back yes so
where do you think there were safety
check safety in terms of what messing up
the molecular of the genome of the one
that you're transferring the genes to
from wild I think same thresholds we
have now one of the first things that's
done when should we say
foreign gene or whatever you like to
call it the gene that you've targeted to
be put into the the variety that you're
wanting to improve the first thing
that's done is to do a molecular
analysis of the transformed or
genetically engineered crop and that's
done at the my newest level looking for
any abnormalities apart from having put
that gene that may have occurred
unexpected ones undesirable ones so at
the molecular level you have to show
that that's the only change that's
occurred so that's how it starts then
once you're satisfied that that is the
case then you start throwing out these
transformed plants and doing all kinds
of checks in the greenhouse to find out
whether the plant itself looks the same
as as the initial variety the non
transform driving etc sex etc so that's
the answer we're starting right from the
very first
analysis of the what they call the event
when you put the gene into the target
crop right from their armors they're
looking for abnormalities and that's
done now it won't be anything new if we
go to looking at a germ plasm correction
taking wild gene from wild potato for
example putting it into a commercial
potato with exactly the same thing look
for abnormalities from that gene and
sometimes you get them too and those
particular events are thrown out does
that answer your question
high-speed you read a drug selection
earlier back in if I have a regulatory
fresh phone that's going to require me
to do four years of evaluation in pick
up new differences I haven't been robbed
just using genomic selection pushing for
generations a year in a greenhouse and
and do it that way than I am
and I think a lot of those are thinking
you really want to edit a thousand
things in it I'm not totally didn't like
their science show that this is keeping
the ones that we did I had no master
this yeah at scale how well at the
beginning I said that GM should not be
used in general as a cure-all that there
it should be used in my opinion only
when other approaches are not going to
work if you have a situation where
another approach will work for
particular crop on a particular trait go
with it even if even if other non-gm
approaches might work
go with them but in those cases where
they will not work or unlikely to work
look into GM I think the single worst is
the best you set up a regular to at one
event it been from application but if
the technology itself is not the issue
ours that one of the questions related
to this is this off cited question about
speed because the early camera work all
you and so the time they were measuring
was already at that point and then just
look at the transfer in and then did not
consider the analysis afterwards and so
they say rejoice and they say breathing
takes a long time of a long time and and
then you don't have the recent
regulatory testing afterwards so has
anybody done setting up the strong name
[Music]
greenhouse regeneration tell you
definitively but I don't know this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu